[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend Ihnen jetzt muss die
Welt an einem Strang ziehen immer
drängender werden die Warnungen aus der
Wissenschaft immer deutlicher zu spüren
sind die verheerenden Auswirkungen der
Klimakrise jetzt müsste die Welt an
einem Strang ziehen morgen beginnt die
UNO Klimakonferenz aber sie wird
überschattet von Krieg Krisen und
Inflation und dazu kommt noch Gastgeber
Ägypten ist in Sachen Klimaschutz und
Meinungsfreiheit alles andere als ein
Vorbild aus Sharm el Sheikh berichtet
goldene atai
es ist nicht leicht für ihn der
Zerstörung immer und immer wieder
zuzusehen wo grün war und alte seltene
Bäume entstehen kommerzflächen der
Anwalt Ahmad assaidi weiß was der Zement
hier bewirkt bei den steigenden
Temperaturen wird seine Stadt Kairo noch
wärmer noch unangenehmer werden für die
Einwohner dagegen will er vor Gericht
ziehen
ägyptischen Gesetzbuch sollte vor jedem
Bau- und Straßenprojekt vorher eine
ökologische Studie zu den möglichen
Folgen angefertigt werden aber solche
Studien interessieren hier einfach
niemanden
im ganzen Land verschwinden immer mehr
Bäume
immer mehr Siedlungen Straßen Brücken
lässt Ägyptens Militärführung aus dem
Boden stampfen für die Klimabilanz des
Gastgebers der Weltklimakonferenz ist
das verheerend
doch die Welt die sich in Sharm
el-Sheikh trifft um das Klima zu retten
weiß nicht wie es woanders im Land
aussieht sie übersieht dass die gerade
gepflanzten Bäume anders als die alten
gewässert werden müssen in der
Klimamodell Stadt mit exklusiver
strandkulisse fahren e-busse Spenden
Solarzellen Licht und sind Fahrräder
selbstverständlich
Normalbürgern ist der Zutritt verwehrt
keine Klimakonferenz wurde mehr
überwacht als die die am Sonntag hier
beginnt
was die Wahl des Gastgebers so
kontrovers macht sind auch zehntausende
politische Gefangene der prominenteste
unter ihnen der demokratieaktivist Allah
Abdel fata verschärft ab morgen seinen
Hungerstreik und verzichtet auf Wasser
mein Bruder will nicht sterben aber wir
wissen seit Jahren des von ganz oben
entschieden wurde in lebenslang im
Gefängnis zu halten
den wenigen im Land verbliebenen
Menschenrechtlern hat Ägyptens Regierung
keinen Einlass zur Konferenz gewährt
Ägypten leidet seit zehn Jahren unter
der Repression der Zivilgesellschaft ein
Klima der Angst unterdrückt die Stimmen
aller Gruppen und Menschen hier die
besonders vom Klimawandel betroffen sind
am Konferenzort ist für Demonstrationen
nur eine abgelegene spezialzone
vorgesehen jeder Demonstrant muss vorher
registriert sein
ja ein schwieriger Gastgeber Afrika
gehört zu denen die die größte Last der
Klimakrise tragen und ist gleichzeitig
mit am wenigsten dafür gerüstet insofern
wäre es ja schon ein Zeichen dass der
Gipfel in Afrika stattfindet guten Abend
golline was müsste denn passieren damit
diese Mammutveranstaltung dann insgesamt
ein Erfolg wird
nun die ägyptische Präsidentschaft sieht
sich ja also eine Art Fürsprecher der
der afrikanischen Nationen und drängt
jetzt sehr darauf dass es statt neuer
versprechen wirklich konkreter
Handlungen gibt das heißt das müssen
geldzusagen gemacht werden es muss Geld
fließen gerade gegenüber den meist
betroffenen Staaten meist Betroffene
Staaten wie zum Beispiel Pakistan aber
auch China die drängen ja auf einen
Entschädigungsfonds und für viele
Industrieländer ist das Wort
Entschädigung immer noch ein tabu-wort
man will es Abbildern man will eine Art
Prozess und dieser Prozess soll sich bis
zur nächsten Thema Konferenz nächstes
Jahr in Dubai ziehen eine Art
Versicherung also alles sieht im Moment
danach aus als ob es diesen globalen
Fonds in diesem Jahr erstmal nicht geben
wird und alles sieht im Moment danach
aus dass diese Klimakonferenz erstmal
eine Art zwischenkonferenz werden wird
ohne wirklich bahnbrechende Ergebnisse
und das zeigen auch die die
Implementation
wieder nur 24 von 193 Staaten haben sich
bis zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt ehrgeizigere
Klimaziele gesetzt jetzt werden wir ja
goldene bei dir 40.000 Teilnehmer
erleben aus aller Welt knapp zwei Wochen
lang Beratungen auf was müssen wir denn
dabei jetzt besonders achten
besonders auf dem Montag und Dienstag es
haben sich über 100 Staatschefs
angekündigt der Bundeskanzler Scholz
wird hier sein der französische
Präsident macron der neue britische
Premier wird hier sein zu den großen
abwesenden Zielen die Präsidenten Chinas
und Russland und Bundeskanzler Scholz
der will vor allen Dingen am am Panel
zum grünen Wasserstoff also dem neuen
Energieträger der Zukunft teilnehmen er
will sich aber auch Treffen mit 27 der
meist betroffenen Staaten und im Umfeld
dieses Gipfels gibt es natürlich auch
Hoffnung dass einige Verträge
geschlossen werden Verträge vor allen
Dingen die auf eine
Energiepartnerschaft hinwirken sollen
eine erneuerbare Energiepartnerschaft
mit den Ländern Nordafrikas und das
Mittleren Ostens goldener Teil live in
Sharm el Sheikh vielen Dank dahin und
damit nach Deutschland wo der
Bundeskanzler wieder gelandet ist nach
seiner China-Reise die ja viel
diskutiert wurde und wird auch in der
eigenen Partei heute das debattenkonvent
über den Kurs der SPD mit Olaf Scholz
und da steht über allem die
Gradwanderung Kanzlerpartei zu sein ohne
kanzlerwahlverein zu werden Lars Bonsack
hat die Genossinnen und Genossen in
Berlin beobachtet
die umfragezahlen sind eher mau die
diesjährigen Wahlen in den Ländern
gingen für die SPD höchst
unterschiedlich aus und dennoch strotzt
die parteivor Selbstbewusstsein spürbar
auf ihrem debattenkonvent in Berlin wir
sind eine Partei die gerade in den
Zeiten der Krisen der Unsicherheit des
Umbruchs auch in Deutschland die sehr
darauf achtet dass das Land
zusammengehalten wird und dass die dass
das soziale Miteinander dass das in
Deutschland nicht verloren geht es geht
um die Zukunft sozialdemokratischer
Politik wie wollen die Genossen mit
Klima Digitalisierung und demografischen
Wandel umgehen dafür gehen sie hier
einen neuen Weg erstmals dürfen auch
nicht Mitglieder mitdiskutieren
ich finde es richtig die Debatten zu
öffnen und gerade in einer Zeit wo
Parteien immer weniger Mitglieder
bekommen muss man auch die Türen öffnen
und die Debatten öffnen und das machen
wir und das finde ich richtig eineinhalb
Stunden hätten Mitglieder wie Gäste Zeit
gehabt dem Kanzler auf den Zahn zu
fühlen tatsächlich wird es zeitweise
eher eine Ehrerbietung ja hallo Johannes
Jusos Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg in erster
Linie vielen Dank für deine Arbeit finde
ich solide erstmal wollte ich auch ich
noch sagen dass du eine wirklich super
Arbeit als Bundeskanzler machst
und selbst mit hoch umstrittenen Themen
wie seiner Reise nach China punktet
Scholz bei den Genossen alleine weil es
gelungen ist dass sowohl die chinesische
Regierung der Präsident als auch ich
dort erklären konnte es dürfen keine
Atomwaffen in diesem Krieg eingesetzt
werden alleine dafür hat sich die ganze
Reise gelohnt der debattenkonvent steht
in einem merkwürdigen Widerspruch zur
sonstigen Stille in der SPD keine
Auseinandersetzungen keine Verletzungen
mehr wie sonst in all den Jahren links
laut und angriffslustig so kannte man
Kevin Kühnert aus seiner Zeit als
juso-chef vorbei die SPD heute ist nicht
mehr die trauerklos SPD von
2018/2019 die SPD von heute hat eine
Bundestagswahl gewonnen stellt den
Kanzler die Hälfte der
Ministerpräsidenten und arbeitet hier an
dem Zukunftsprogramm da muss ich doch
hier nicht wie ein Schluck Wasser
rumlaufen fast ein Viertel der
Bundestagsabgeordneten der SPD sind
Jusos jahrzehntelang waren die der
Stachel im Fleisch der SPD auch das
vorbei es muss ein klares
gerechtigkeitsprofil der SPD geben wenn
das der Fall ist dann sind wir auch als
Jusos zufrieden am Ende heißt es dann
noch Schlange stehen für ein selfie mit
Olaf Scholz die SPD ist auf dem besten
Wege ein kanzlerwahlverein zu werden
so wir bleiben noch Moment in der
Bundespolitik an diesem Samstag und zwar
jetzt mit Diana ja denn trotz der
jüngsten Nachbesserungen der Stempel am
geplanten Bürgergeld zeigt sich die
Union weiterhin nicht überzeugt der
stellvertretende
CDU-Fraktionsvorsitzende Gröhe
kritisierte unter anderem dass es zu
Beginn des Leistungsbezugs zu wenig
Sanktionsmöglichkeiten bei
Pflichtverletzungen gebe SPD-Chef
Klingbeil warf der Union die Verbreitung
von Fake News vor dabei geht es um die
Aussage dass bürgergeldbezieher künftig
mehr Geld zur Verfügung hätten als
manche Arbeitnehmer mit niedrigem
Einkommen
die Tafeln in Deutschland schlagen Alarm
seit Jahresbeginn sei die Zahl der Hilfe
suchenden um 50% gestiegen sagte der
Vorsitzende des Tafel Dachverbands Brühl
der Rheinischen Post insgesamt kämen
etwa 2 Millionen Menschen gleichzeitig
würden allerdings weniger Lebensmittel
gespendet
gegenüberlastung hätten rund ein Drittel
der Tafeln Aufnahmestopps verhängt
Iran hat erstmals zugegeben eine
begrenzte Zahl von Kampfdrohnen an
Russland geliefert zu haben und zwar
Monate vor dem Angriffskrieg das sagte
Irans Außenminister der staatlichen
Nachrichtenagentur irner der ukrainische
Präsident selenski war Teheran daraufhin
mit Blick auf den genannten Umfang der
Lieferungen Lügen vor täglich würde die
Ukraine mindestens zehn iranische
Drohnen abschießen
um sich solidarisch mit den Protesten in
Iran zu zeigen und zugleich Hilfe für
die Ukraine zu fordern sind heute in
Köln tausende Menschen auf die Straße
gegangen unter dem Titel Marsch für die
Freiheit forderten sie etwa mehr Druck
für die auf die iranische Regierung und
Sanktionen gegen Russland
niemand kontrolliert mehr helfen
weltweit als China mit wirtschaftlicher
Macht politischen Einfluss zu gewinnen
diese aggressive Politik geht auf auch
in Europa eine Autobahn in Montenegro
Eisenbahn in Ungarn die helfen von
Piräus Rotterdam Antwerpen le avre
Bilbao Marseille überall mischt Peking
mit bei einem Terminal im Hamburger
Hafen ist China nach heftiger Diskussion
jetzt mit einer Minderheitsbeteiligung
dabei ein warnendes Beispiel welche
Folgen so etwas haben kann ist Sri Lanka
der Inselstaat liegt zwar mehr als 3000
Kilometer Luftlinie entfernt vom
chinesischen Festland aber strategisch
günstig an einer der wichtigsten
Handelsrouten der Welt und Sri Lanka ist
pleite Milliardengelder aus China wurden
zu Milliarden Schulden für Sri Lanka
neben einem komplett neuen Stadtteil am
Hafen hat Peking der Hauptstadt Colombo
einen schicken Turm in die Skyline
gepflanzt Norman
350 Meter rauf in den Himmel über
Colombo der lotusturm sollte zum Symbol
für den aufschwungsrelankas werden er
ist ein Mahnmal der Krise nicht zuletzt
wegen solcher egozentrischen Bauprojekte
ist Sri Lanka Pleite die Tafel unten
bedankt sich dennoch artig bei den
Schöpfern fast alle hören auf den Namen
Raja paxa die inzwischen aus den Ämtern
Gejagte Politiker Dynastie wegen
Machtmissbrauchs Korruption 113
Millionen Euro für einen Turm den keiner
braucht finanziert mit Krediten aus
China Brombach offiziell beschreibt
China solche Projekte gern als
wohlwollende Entwicklung im Rahmen der
seitenstraßeninitiative wirtschaftlicher
Aufbau Kooperation aber ein genauerer
Blick zeigt das ist nicht unpolitisch
alles was China macht hat politische und
strategische Ziele
so profitiert eben doch einer vom
Turmbau zu Colombo China und die
Aussicht offenbart dass es dabei nicht
bleibt da unten entsteht port city 270
Hektar mit Sand aufgeschüttet wieder
kommt das meiste Geld aus China das eine
Sonderwirtschaftszone errichten will die
Verträge undurchsichtig was durchsickert
lässt befürchten das Wohl und Wehe dabei
ungerecht verteilt sind so ist das
Prinzip
[Musik]
ist Lake stellen Sie sich vor die Bank
sagt okay ich gebe dir den Kredit damit
kannst du dein Haus bauen aber alle
Steine dafür musst du bei mir kaufen und
du musst meine Arbeiter beschäftigen so
macht China das 90 Prozent des Kredits
fließt damit zurück in Chinas Taschen
und dann zahlen wir noch 12% Zinsen
dafür das ist kein faires Geschäft sie
ist
im Süden Sri Lankas hier einen
Tiefseehafen zu bauen hielten viele für
ein wirtschaftliches Wagnis aber Peking
ermutigte und gab das Geld als Sri Lanka
die Kredite nicht mehr bedienen konnte
wurde der Hafen verpachtet für 99 Jahre
an China na klar ein Deal dubios genug
um Gerüchte zu befeuern plant Peking
eine Militärbasis die Lage am Indischen
Ozean wäre perfekt was jetzt genau im
Hafen passiert ist unklar und unsichtbar
sogar der offizielle Aussichtspunkt ist
für Ausländer gesperrt
China schenkt uns nichts ihr Ziel ist
nichts Sri Lanka etwas Gutes zu tun sie
haben wirtschaftliche Interessen und
politische Interessen das Problem ist
was sollen wir machen wir brauchen das
Geld wir brauchen Investitionen und kein
anderer gibt es investments and nobody
is coming
ein klammes Land in dem die Korruption
blüht Sri Lanka schien der ideale
Partner für Chinas Initiativen
mehrfacher die Regierungen Colombo
inzwischen um Schuldenerlass gebeten
aber Peking bietet nur neue Kredite
sieht so aus als hängesri Lanka am Haken
die in der Türkei geborene
Schriftstellerin Schauspielerin und
Theaterregisseurin Emine sevg
Büchner-Preis ausgezeichnet worden die
deutsche Sprache und Literatur
verdankten
öfter mal neue Horizonte Themen und
einen hochpoetischen Sound so die
Begründung der Jury ihre Dankesrede
widmete östermann Georg Büchner den sie
als Vorbild und Bruder Figur bezeichnete
die 76-Jährige kam erstmals 1965 nach
Deutschland ohne ein Wort Deutsch zu
verstehen der Büchnerpreis gehört zu den
bedeutendsten deutschen Literaturpreisen
und jetzt die Lottozahlen von diesem
Samstag die lauten 12 27 32 35 39 42
Superzahl 8 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
fehlen noch die Wetteraussichten morgen
im Nordwesten und Westen dichte Wolken
und etwas Regen sonst teils heiter teils
wolkig Lokal auch länger neblig trüb
Höchstwerte 7 bis 13 Grad die weiteren
Aussichten leicht wechselhaft mit einer
Mischung aus vielen Wolken ein paar
Schauern aber auch sonnigen Abschnitten
sowie milden Temperaturen zwischen 11
und 19 Grad ja und damit entlassen wir
sie in einen hoffentlich angenehmen
Samstagabend und sehen Sie gerne morgen
wieder tschüss
[Musik]